[Music]
we have the opportunity you and I to to
have a meal not too long ago I mean
you're amazing
[Applause]
anybody who meets me and then it makes
my wife is always like how did you get
her you did and your kids are taller
than me I might go to bed they're in
their 50s I'm curious about something
which is you you brought your boyfriend
along who I love he's a great guy and
he's such a terrific Dana Dana with a
man with a woman's name man a woman's
name and and he's I find out that he's
the producer behind great great films
captain Phillips
and he's producing Fifty Shades of Grey
and I was actually kind of thinking
maybe I could get into Fifty Shades of
Grey why does that make people laugh
sensual man we watch your show and
Dana's like he's at it again he really
wants to be in the movie you're not you
are not going to be in 50 so he's the
producer yes people the crowd you're
already losing ticket sales people see
me as that kind of guy they know that
I'm this way on camera but behind the
scenes I'm a perv okay you know I took
him home to meet my parents
you said you take Danny your boyfriend
to Oklahoma Oklahoma and you know we're
conservative there I come from a
conservative Christian family and then
my dad goes now Dana Dana what you can't
get over your room is at the end of the
hall and Christian yours upstairs I'm
like it's just how we do it here in the
south and you know we we hold hands
before we pray each meal and I forgot to
warn Dana about that and I my dad's like
I mean look at Dana
Dana's like he wants me to hold his hand
yeah it's like uh socially it's a
slightly awkward thing if you're not
used to it I should have worn component
of course and then my mom goes now are
you doing that porn movie and he said
not weapons she's that Fifty Shades of
something it's porn I read it I read it
this is so great this is your boyfriend
bring him home to Oklahoma and they
think he's producing porn but I did get
all these um these toys not from FAO
Schwartz but other PI's from the
producers of the movie not him you've
got Fifty Shades of Grey
well nothing that does that I think
you just did that makes pasta I don't
want to get caught in that thing
seriously you're acting out strange
stuff there are certain toys I can
imagine but when you're like yeah
there's a toy and then bang and we you
know different things I thought it's a
dusting thing you dust with it no it's
not it's for the better
anyway they see them all over and I
don't know what that's good
I don't either I don't want to know Andy
you're a perv you know what at gusting I
guess it would be like some kind of
tickle torture I think yeah see that
would be my yeah well I hope there are
instructions because you use one of
these things wrong and man right in a
lot of trouble right they are and
they're pulling of what you know what I
mean it's
seriously they're like I did what I know
no you tinker with it you don't you know
what are we doing it's no good for
dusting now